[Music]
this is going to be a talk that's in two
parts the second half is going to be
about tips for writing better predictive
models it's actually different from a
bunch of examples that have lessons that
the data science machine learning team
is fourscore has learned over the past
several years in order to understand the
context for those examples I necessarily
have to explain to you what fourscore
does as a company and so I'm going to
start with a brief introduction of what
fourscore does so this is what
Foursquare used to do in 2014
forescore used to be a location-based a
location-based social network and this
is the reason why I joined the company I
used I was a very avid user of this app
and I defended my mayorships around New
York City with many thousands of
check-ins and when I use the app I like
the data that the app gave me and so I
eagerly joined the data science team at
Foursquare in order to get my hands on
this data so a few months after I joined
fourscore split the app into they became
fourscore city garden swarm city guide
is a local search and recommendation
engine it helps users find places in
this world and swarm is the app which
continues the original Foursquare
tradition of using your mobile phone to
check-in the places in 2016 the company
pivoted again and this was a much more
dramatic change than splitting the apps
in 2014 forescore started to focus on
being an enterprise business and we
rebranded ourselves as Foursquare
location intelligence so what does that
mean if you look in Wikipedia it says
location intelligence is a business of
deriving meaningful relationships using
geospatial data but the way I like to
say it is Foursquare understands where
people go in this world so an example of
location intelligence is the project
that I work on called pilgrim so what is
pilgrim pilgrim was born in 2013 and
when it was born Wired magazine wrote an
article by that they called it the
brilliant hack that brought Foursquare
back from the dead and I loved this
article but actually really disliked the
headline because number one fourscore
wasn't dead in 2013 and number two what
they called a brilliant hack was just a
bit of applied machine learning and it
ran in the background of the phone and
the predicted if the user was likely to
check into a place and this was used
in many many different places for
instance we were able to remind people
to check into places because you have to
understand checking into place is very
disruptive for most users in order to
check into a place you have to pull out
your phone you have to unlock it you
have to find the app you have to click
on the button of a lot of different
buttons to confirm you're out of place
and people can't or don't always want to
do that that's a lot of friction and so
now with these with these push
notifications we can have users generate
check-ins with just one swipe we were
able to push useful tips city guide can
push useful tips to people about places
that they go to and eventually we were
able to populate the user feed and swarm
with passively detected check-ins and
here's an example from my phone instead
of checking in five times a place at
five times a day at places like I said
that's disruptive I can check in two
places once a day and I retro actively
creative child trail check-ins and I can
still defend my mayorship without having
being without having to be that socially
reared person he's always on their phone
so when Foursquare pivoted in 2016 one
of the very first things we did was we
took pilgrim and we wrapped it in an SDK
and we let other companies demo it and
one of the first companies a demo it is
a Canadian company called touch tombs so
touch teens is an app which you can use
to control jukeboxes from your phone
they have software installed in
jukeboxes in 65 different places at 65
thousand different places in North
America you can buy credits on your
phone you can browse playlists you can
queue up songs which you like but touch
teens has a problem which a lot of apps
have which that people download it they
demo it and then they forget that it's
on their phone after a couple of days
and so touch teens use the poem SDK to
deliver these very precise pings and
here's a picture from my phone I go to
Midtown
I beat my husband after work and then
touch tunes reminds me if I go into a
bar I've never been to before touch
Tunes can remind me number one that I
have unused credits sitting around and
number two that my favorite song is on
that phone and if I swipe through that
ping I can play my favorite song so
touch tunes demo this and they found a
huge spike in engagement they had four
times as much engagement and they had
twice as much monetization per user
simply by being able to deliver these
accurate pings so I want to give you an
overview of the data that pilgrim team
house gets to work with first and
foremost we have check-ins which come
from swarm and this is a data source
which we know and love and we understand
really well in order to create a
check-in I click on this pin at the
bottom of the screen I get presented
with a list of places nearby they are
more or less ranked by the likelihood
that I'm at that place and if I pick one
of those places that creates a check-in
for the swarm app so the same flow is
found in other apps like Twitter and
reddit here is my phone I'm composing a
tweet about how much I like turtles I
click on this pin which looks a lot like
the pin and swarm and lo and behold I
get a ranked list of places and actually
it's this is generated by four scores
technology so it's the same list of
places at Foursquare that you would see
in four scores swarm remember the
example I gave you about the pilgrim SDK
I just realized I misspelled pilgrim but
the pilgrim SDK so when a user swipes
through a ping to play a song in a bar
that is we get that data back and that
effectively becomes a check-in because
that that's a confirmation that the user
was at a place at a certain time and we
also have user confirmation if this
passively detected feed it's an apps
like tinder and TripAdvisor here's a
picture of the passive feed and
TripAdvisor it's it's a feature called
travel timeline that you can turn it on
and you can see the places where
TripAdvisor using the pilgrim SDK thinks
that you were during the day and you can
confirm and deny that and so all of this
data which comes from both from our
first party apps and also from our
partners I'm going to call check-ins
internally we call them something
slightly different but for the purposes
of this talk there are check-ins and
just to give you an example of the scale
of the growth of Foursquare this is not
the amount of check-ins we have this is
the rate at which we're detecting
check-ins and it's growing exponentially
we're currently able to detect 3 billion
check-ins every month and we are active
on about 375 million mobile phones
worldwide and last thing I want to say
in this introduction is
that the pilgrim SEK isn't the only
example of location intelligence
Foursquare partners with a lot of brands
with a lot of different solutions we
have an API which is independent of s CK
we have an attribution pipeline which is
basically ad tech we have some media
solutions and we also have an analytics
dashboard that our partners use in order
to understand foot traffic which goes to
and from their brick-and-mortar shelves
so lesson number one is to track the
right metrics I know this doesn't sound
original but it can't be repeated often
enough so let's start with the data we
have we have 105 million places in this
world according to Foursquare database
so we have an in-house database which we
own which we think models the places in
this world every time you want to snap
the user to this place we retrieve 200
candidates they are the 200 candidates
which according to a mobile phone are
the most relevant ones and we score them
so we have about 50 different features
and we calculate 50 features for 200
candidates we get a 50 by 200 feature
matrix we run that through a machine
learning model we create a ranked list
of places you buy and we send that back
to the phone so two things about this
flow number one everything on the bottom
here this is not an original design
pattern it's we did not invent it this
is a very common way of this is a very
common pattern that's used to serve
search and recommendation engines number
two everything down here is actually
done service is done server-side we
don't keep the database on the phone we
don't do the machine learning on the
phone we do it on the servers so a phone
will initiate this process and then it
gets the ranked list of candidates back
so example of some of the features which
we calculate there themselves machine
learn features here is a pretty picture
which comes from an animation for a
feature we have called play shapes and
since this is a technical audience I can
finally say this place shapes is a
Gaussian mixture model it's a linear
combination of gaussians it's a surface
it's a probability distribution surface
which is higher where check-ins are
dense and it's lower lower check-ins are
sparse so every single one of these pink
and purple dots is the lat/long this is
the coordinates of a check-in to a venue
to a restaurant in Manhattan
and we're a real calculate Scouts this
Gaussian mixture model and furthermore
we calculate the level sets the
horizontal slices of this mixture model
and we can derive what the places of
shapes are and we have one of these
models for all hunt for each of the
hundred five million places I don't want
to go too much into all the features we
have I want to say just as a generality
we have about 50 features and you can
group them we have place shapes we have
a global index of Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
skins that we can create from data
that's associated with check-ins we have
information about the popularity of a
place real time popularity for instance
Madison Square eats or if there is a
football game that's happening nearby we
get that information in real time and
that's some of the signals which we use
in our model we have some personalized
signals for users and we have some for
time of day and they'll talk about the
time of day features later so if you're
interested in the stack and you want to
know more details because I'm not going
to go into any more details now I
encourage you to read this paper that
fourscore published in 2013 they
describe in detail the features that
were used then five years ago and at the
end of the paper they use these features
to evaluate a dozen different models
against each other and they conclude
that lambda Mart had the best precision
at one and so in 2013 for score
production Ives version of lambda Mart
and shipped it we don't use lambda Mart
anymore we actually use actually boost
but it's still a gradient boosted tree
model so I'm going to be talking about
tree models for the rest of this talk so
my first question was is you need to be
tracked in my first lesson is that you
need to be tracking the right metrics so
my question for you is is precision at
one really the right metric to use when
you're evaluating these models against
each other so you might think yes
because that is obviously like we need
to be accurate but you might think no
because the way that Stephanie set up
this talk it seems like the answer to
this question is no so the answer is
both yes and no I want to say in 2013
within the context of Foursquare having
unified app it was the right metric to
track now it is not the most important
metric and so what has changed is that
in 2013 we had this closed system we had
an app which created data the data went
into machine learning model on the
she learning model served the app and
that was this closed system and so we
wanted to be accurate and we wanted to
reduce friction for when people checked
into places and so it was the right
thing to look at but now that the
assumption that we have this closed
system is broken we have some people who
use our SDK some companies using our API
some companies just want analytics and
they're not giving us any data and
predicting where somebody's likely to
check in is actually different from
predicting where they really are so I'll
give you a concrete example we'll go
back to our database of 105 million
places some places are inside of other
places we know that we model that
instead of this being a flat database
what this is is actually a database of
trees so every record optionally has a
pointer which points to another record
and that pointer is defined if you are a
Starbucks inside of a Target or if
you're j.crew inside of another mall so
you have this database of trees there's
no loops everything has zero or one
parent and arbitrary number of children
so here is a this is what we call
internally a venue hierarchy so I'm
going to start saying the word hierarchy
because I can't unlearn that vocabulary
this is a grossly oversimplified
hierarchy from New York City the real
hierarchy has hundreds of venues but I
just pulled about the half dozen for
this example in New York City there's a
building called the Time Warner Center
and I see that people are nodding their
head because they're familiar with this
inside of Time Warner Center there's a
shopping mall in the basement there is a
Whole Foods and in the sub-basement
there's a gym called Equinox so what
happens in real life is I could be
shopping at H&M and that means I'm at
the Shops at Columbus Circle and it
simultaneously means I'm at the Time
Warner Center but we know fourscore
knows from extensive studies and it's
also intuitive that the higher up in the
hierarchy that we go the more likely a
user is to confirm that they're at that
place and so we have virtually a hundred
percent accuracy if we guess that
somebody's at the Time Warner Center
because the Time Warner Center is big it
has a big footprint we have a lot of
data about it we're a little bit less
accurate weren't trying to guess if
somebody's at the shopping mall and
we're maybe 60 percent accurate weren't
trying to guess that somebody's within a
place of the shopping mall so if the
only thing
Karin about was precision at one then I
would be incentivized to show the Time
Warner Center the time warner center at
the top of every single prediction
because that's what the users likely to
to to confirm however you have to
understand the business value of our
data comes from understanding where
people go and also for analytics clients
we have to understand where people go
and spend their money and so I actually
prefer a model that takes a 60% chance
guessing that somebody's at H&M then
100% chance of their at the Time Warner
Center furthermore we have the hierarchy
and so if you know they're at H&M we
know that they're at the time winners
center and so this is an example where
over emphasizing the precision at one
actually hurts the business value of our
data and so I wish I can go with into
all the formulas that we use of the
equations that we use for these metrics
and I'm not going to I'm going to say
that whenever we evaluate a machine
learning model we actually evaluate it
on about a dozen different metrics and
you can put them into groups one of the
metrics that we look at are the
traditional machine learning metrics
that you find that you learn in school
you find in literature so we look at
precision under the curve an area under
the curve and and in law gloss and the
traditional things like that but
alongside those data science driven
metrics we have a bunch of product
driven metrics and they answer questions
like are we detecting the right places
in the hierarchy which I just talked
about they also we also worry about
detecting just the same places over and
over again and I'm going to talk about
that later and generally speaking we we
worry about whether or not our data
makes sense when compared to the real
world and events that happen in the real
world for so an example of that is
something that happened in 2016 there
was an e.coli scare and sapote Lee was
forced it was in the supply chain of
Chipotle and they were forced to close a
bunch of stores this was immediately
after the Foursquare pivot to enterprise
and when we saw foot traffic to Chipotle
fall in real-time and we published very
early actually at the very end of that
incident in the very beginning of the
recovery we published that we saw a foot
traffic fall by 30 percent and it wasn't
until the end of the quarter that
Chipotle went out and said that their
sales had fallen by twenty nine point
seven percent and so that's the type of
thing that we worry about because being
accurate doesn't guarantee that
your data is useful it's correlated
that's not a guarantee so that's the end
of my first lesson the second lesson is
about feature engineering I put an
asterisk next put an asterisk next to
this because I realize that many people
here are experts in deep learning in my
understanding of neural networks is that
you don't have to engineer features but
if you're not working in that space
feature engineering is really important
and I want to walk you through several
generations of one of the features which
we enjoy at Foursquare and I'll explain
to you the mistakes that we made so this
is the feature which has to do with the
time of day and I'm showing you the same
picture that I use for play shapes but
instead of focusing on the top let's
just focus on the bottom here this is a
time series and it shows the rate at
which people visit this restaurant it's
a highly repeatable pattern and you can
see that it will be very useful for a
machine learning model and also you just
think if you stand on a random street
corner in New York City the landscape of
places that people are at at 11:00 p.m.
on Saturday night is completely
different from even 12 hours later 11
a.m. sunday morning completely different
so time of day is a really useful
feature and our first attempt to encode
this into into a feature that our model
used was fairly naive we just used a
bunch of categorical variables so we had
a seven-layer category variable for a
day of week this is this isn't actually
production code I'm just mocking it up
and we had a 14 layer categorical
variable for our of day Y 14 I don't
remember it was hours of the day in
groups of 1 or 2 and we also already had
in our model a categorical variable for
the place category examples of place
categories are like bodegas nightclubs
restaurants shopping and we were
expecting the model to learn this
complicated relationship between three
categorical variables we were expecting
the decision tree does it have a path in
it that looked like if it's 11 p.m. and
if happens to be Saturday and if you
happen to be a nightclub then people are
more likely to be here but if it's 11
p.m. and it happens to be an office and
people are less likely to be here and
this didn't work no matter how much data
we gave the model it never learned these
types of relationships
and so this what we were expecting the
model to learn
we took that logic and we moved it into
the feature engineering side of things
so version 2 of this feature was to use
histograms and so we took timestamps of
check-ins that we detected we group them
by place and we created histograms and
this is example of one of the histograms
there's a hundred and sixty-eight bins
in the bottom because 160 is 24 times 7
so I labeled the groups of seven so you
can understand this is the histogram for
a popular Caribbean restaurant which
happens to be a bar at night and so you
can see Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday night people really love this
bar and the second version of the
feature which we served was simply the
height of the normalized histogram so we
normalized these histogram so that the
sum of the bars adds up to 1 and then if
it's Saturday night at 11:00 p.m. we
look up the hours of the week and we say
ok we're going to serve or the value for
this feature for this bar happens to be
about that right there and then all the
offices nearby the similar histogram if
you overlaid it they don't have these
really small bars because hopefully not
that many people are working Saturday
night 11:00 p.m. and so now we have this
feature which is better and we think
it's monotonic we think that the higher
it is the more likely people are going
to be at that place because they happen
to be at that place in the past and
before reproduction dies this we
actually made what we thought was an
improvement we treated the histogram
like a frequentist probability and we
approximated the PDF using a cosine
basis there were two reasons why we did
this number one it's smoother because
some of the histograms don't have that
much data see and there but the like
that's like really jagged pattern and
the the Fourier approximation smooth
that and number two it compressed the
amount of data that we had to serve
that's because we're detecting three
billion visits and each visit we have to
calculate the score on 200 venues and at
that scale in the amount of compression
counts for a lot and but we still have
this monotonic feature and it's high
when we think that people are likely to
be at place and it's low when we think
that people aren't going to be at that
place and we serve this and it was
incredible
it was incredibly bad it didn't work it
added no predictive value to anything
and it didn't stop us from guessing that
people are at nightclubs at seven
o'clock on Tuesday morning and so to
figure out why we had to look into the
details of the extra boost remodel which
he trained and we looked at every single
node in this family of trees and we
tried to understand how the decision
trees were splitting based on this
feature and try and explain to you what
we saw here is another picture of the
Fourier appraoch time series feature for
two different venues one of them happens
to be an airport one of them is a fried
chicken joint
and you can see Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday people like eating their
fried chicken at lunch and especially
dinnertime breakfast not so much and
that the weekends people are checking
into the airports kind of at the same
rate that they are during the day and
once again this is the for the the fried
chicken signal in particular is really
low in the morning is really high in the
evening and if you look really really
closely you can see something else it's
actually not here up here that picture
of fried chicken actually isn't a
picture of fried chicken I want you to
know it's actually a picture of puppies
which I found online which I thought
look like fried chicken so okay I just
wanted this check if people are paying
attention so let's go back to these time
series I'm going to replace the fried
chicken joint with a restaurant that is
not very popular and the 40 models look
like this so the airport stays the same
but it looks like it's squashed because
the Y values the range of the Y values
is now a lot larger right and
furthermore you look at this time series
in light blue and it just doesn't really
make any sense we only had this was a
place which had I think about 30 visits
or 30 check-ins and it just wasn't
enough data to get meaningful Fourier
coefficients and if you look at the
scale if you look at the range of this
feature you can see it ranges from about
minus 3 to positive 13 and that's bad
because the good well behaved type
series which I showed you earlier
arranged between 0 & 2
and so when we are looking at the
decision trees we were finding that the
decision tree was splitting on values
that were like minus five positive
twenty positive forty and I think I saw
a positive fifty-five in there and what
we realized was that the bad the
unpopular places these malformed time
series for unpopular places were
dominating the way that our model was
learning and so to put this succinctly
on the internet there's a meme it's
called expectations versus reality where
people often post pictures of food it's
usually food for saying what to make or
which they want to receive at a
restaurant and they post pictures of the
reality and it's something really awful
well we were living in that world we
thought that we had created this feature
and it was clever used Fourier series
pretty pictures and if it was high then
you were likely to be out of place and
the reality was we created this feature
and if it was high the model learned
well it's really high and that's because
this place really sucks nobody goes here
so you have a really mouths malformed
signal and that's why the signal didn't
work because what we thought was going
to be a timeless single was in effect of
popularity signal but we already had
half a dozen good popularity signals so
this signal was just adding redundant
information and it was doing it in a
very noisy way and so the model just
ignored it and that's why I had no
predictive value and it wasn't helping
us so once we understood this we were
able to fix it and we did it in a way
that I think Jim savage talked about
this morning we put a prior on every
single place and that prior was based on
similar information so now if you are a
brand new Jim and you've only been
around for a month and we've only
detected 50 check-ins to your place now
we can actually see that for a model
with with check-ins at that gyms that
happen to be nearby and now we can
ensure that every single for you model
has enough data in order to have a
meaningful range and that actually
worked and that's the model that's the
time model that we have in production
today so tip number three is to know
your data like tip number one this isn't
terribly original but it still needs to
be repeated and especially needs to be
repeated at the place
like Foursquare because four score for
score likes to brag about how good our
data is and whenever we we have articles
about our data we always talk about how
good our data is in terms of pirate
booty for some reason they always say
four score sitting on this gold mine of
data this treasure trove of check-ins
and they mean two things number one four
score has labeled training data which is
incredibly useful number two
Foursquare controls the technology which
generates this data because everything
we use comes from the API which we wrote
or the SDK which we wrote and it uses
the same database which we own and from
the point of view of a data scientist
this is a godsend this is amazingly this
is such a gift but it doesn't mean that
our job is any easier it doesn't mean
that we just take these labels and run
it through a machine learning model and
serve it there's still a lot of work to
do in our data I'll give you an example
of that I ran a query last year I was
trying to understand the distribution of
Foursquare check-ins and so I was trying
to understand within the six-month
period how many times we detected only
one check-in to a place or T check-in to
two check-ins to a place so I have a
distribution like this and this says
within our database there are about 16
million places that we've detected
exactly one Check Into over six months
there's about half as many that we
detect two check-ins to over six months
there's about a third as many that we
detected three check-ins to and actually
for any value of n the number of places
that we detected and visits to is
proportional to one over n and I was
able to check this globally it's pretty
simple you take the logarithm of the
x-axis you take the logarithm of the
y-axis you see whether or not your data
falls in the straight line and voila
it's more or less a straight line and
this is example of a statistical
observation called sips law it's a very
particular distribution and zips law
most of you are probably familiar with
it but if you're not zips law is a bit
like the golden ratio it's not like the
law of large numbers which is provable
from first principles and from axioms
it's actually more like it's one of
these things which you see and then once
you learn about you see everywhere and
it's just an observation that this
distribution holds for certain types of
data sets including the type of data set
which we have
so the original version of zip slaw I
pulled this from Wikipedia the original
version of zips law holds for language
where I think it said something like
here's the 30 most most spoken languages
in the world and the number of times
which award shows up and we keep
Wikipedia has one of these distributions
here you can see they take the log of
the x-axis on the log of the y-axis and
there's a whole cottage industry of blog
posts and articles which say zips law
holds for X it's been shown to hold four
NBA scores it holds for distribution of
corporate wealth it holds for here's an
article which says it holds for a
population size of cities so we know
that zips law holds for our ground truth
database of Foursquare but it doesn't
hold everywhere in our stack I took the
same query which generated that original
picture and I pointed it at another
partner stack and I saw something like
this I'll try and put this in context if
you remember on our server we have 105
million places and we over always trying
to retrieve the most relevant places
well in our ground truth database we
know we have a zipfian distribution for
the distribution of the number of
check-ins that we detected this is a
little hard to explain but bear with me
post retrieval we don't have a zipfian
distribution anymore if you only have
one detected check-in it's very unlikely
that you're going to survive this
retrieval stage and this is a very
conscious decision that our server
engineers made because this retrieval
phase it has to have two properties in
order to make our technology work well
number one it has to have high coverage
meaning that it retrieves the correct
candidate as often as possible and
number two it needs to be lean because
this is a very intensive computation
here and we know if we start retrieving
250 or 300 candidates we have
instrumentation on our servers and we
know that we start throwing more
timeouts we start throwing more 400s and
that's bad so we want to have we have
high high success with our retrieval
high coverage and be lean at the same
time and so strategically we've built
into into our retrieval process that we
retrieve popular places more often and
that's fine
the problem with this is that oops yeah
this part right here that's in the light
blue all of this gets log and it becomes
it gets compared against user feedback
and this is used for training future
generations of models and this
introduces a feedback loop into our
machine learning
that's actually pretty vicious so the
feedback loop looks like this a place is
somewhat popular it gets retrieved more
often because that's the that is what we
encoded strategically into our
retrievers if it gets retrieved more
often it gets shown to people slightly
more often and it gets confirmed a
little bit more often and once it gets
confirmed more often it becomes even
more popular and this is something that
we knew about in our technology one of
the engineering managers gave me this
picture he was talking about visit
gravity and his analogy was was using
was was this picture right here he said
that once a place like JFK was an
example once it got a certain number of
check-ins so then it started stealing
predictions from all the nearby places
and then pretty soon if he just happen
to be in the neighborhood there they
always thinks you're at JFK cuz a lot of
people check into JFK and this was a
problem with our technology that we were
able to solve simply by resampling and
so it's very similar in data science if
you have a really unbiased data set
where you were you where you over
represent negative values and under
represent positive values of the vice
versa vice versa what we actually did
was we actually do today is we
understand popular places and we over
sample on popular places in our training
data set and the way we know that we're
doing it or the way we believe that
we're doing it correctly is that we're
using zip slaw as a guide because we
believe that zips law represents the
ground truth for distribution
distribution of places above visits to
places in this world and so in order to
test whether or not this was working we
actually trained we trained five
different models each model had varying
levels of aggressiveness in terms of how
we resampled and we plotted something
which looked like this and this goes
back to the very first lesson I was
talking about we plotted two metrics
against each other one of em was
precision and the other one is a metric
which we internally call place coverage
it's simply the number of the seat
places that our technology can detect
within a week so it's literally the
sequel queries select distinct place ID
from the database of visits and if you
look at the scale of this curve here
around the 0.999 that means that we take
a zero point zero point one percent loss
in precision if you've read this across
we get the parameters for model which
has about nine percent greater coverage
so this translated to millions of
venniese which used to be hidden by this
gravitational pole effect which we are
able to expose but the cost of exposing
it was one correct prediction out of
every thousand and so the data science
team was able to calculate this we call
this the purrito curve and we showed it
the four score leadership and we
explained them what the two metrics were
because I think they're fairly easy to
understand and four score leadership
picked a point on this curve which they
thought was the most the best value for
the business and that is what we have in
production today and so to summarize I
want to emphasize the three the three
lessons which we learned or to keep make
sure you're keeping track of the right
metrics don't undervalue don't
underestimate the value of engineering
your features and make sure you know
your data no matter how good you think
it is there's usually something you can
learn just by rolling up your sleeves
and diving in there for for some time
and so before I end I went to credit
where credit's due I didn't do all this
work myself this is actually done by a
talented team of machine learning
machine learning engineers and servant
engineers and data scientists at
Foursquare and like every other company
at this conference we are also hiring
we're looking for data scientists data
engineers managers and so forth and so
if you're interested come talk to me I
have four co-workers who are in the
audience they will be at my office hours
that office will be at coffee so you can
talk to us and that's the end of my talk
thank you very much
[Applause]
locations and popularity so the question
is how different is our place data from
Google Maps they do and they are and
they are a competitor to some parts of
Foursquare technology I can't speak for
the places database I can speak for the
the accuracy of the predictions because
we have side-by-side studies with many
of our competitors and we probably
shouldn't do this but we have some apps
are for an SDK side-by-side with the
competitors of our SDK and we are at
least 10 points 10 percentage points
more accurate than others so primarily
because we have so much labeled data
yeah yeah
yes the question was if there is use
case for ephemeral events the answer is
yes though I can't think of an example
off the top of my head we are able to
detect those and often we know about
them in advance and so if you use a
swarm app a lot of times when you check
in if we think that there is a specific
event happening we actually write before
you create the check-in we ask you to
confirm that you're at that specific
event so we do that for a lot for movie
openings we do that for Mathers and
score eats like I said and so we have
that data and it's in the real time
database that we can pull at any time as
far as a use cases downstream I I can't
answer that but I'm fairly certain yes
there is an application for it but I
don't think it's any of the ones that
when I was showing you the picture of
the brands that we have is actually not
one of the things that we do right now
so
[Music]